over the past few decades the
freeze-thaw cycle on this bridge has
resulted in cracks that span the entire
depth of the bridge the crew prepared
for the job by erecting wood shielding
on the underside of the deck this
ensures that their work debris won't
fall on the railroad tracks below first
the crew has to jackhammer out every
inch of concrete the men will cut
through the rebar and climb inside the
hole to erect the plywood form on which
the new concrete will be poured
once the form is in place the crew will
tie in brand new rebar lastly they'll
fill the hole with rapidset concrete
like a well-oiled assembly line the men
ready their drills and air hoses
preparing for a long night of
jackhammering ahead even with every man
on the job this process could take over
four hours and with Jay still in the
emergency room the men have to shoulder
his share of the work but in his haste
to get started
eric has forgotten one very important
thing
in the middle of the night staying
visible is crucial to staying alive
unlike a partial repair tonight they had
to jackhammer out all the concrete 108
cubic feet until they're left with only
rebar
their cameras nothing but a vibrating
pry bar
jackhammering four to six hours a night
it start to not feel eat hands and stuff
always trying to stretch it like
tingling all the time even wake up in
the morning this though like Doug Jackie
was 190 pounds
then you figure the bets a couple of
pounds plus all the hoes you drag around
the hammer punches right through a hole
and there's nothing holding it up but
the rebar and yourself the skid steers
move in to clear out the rubble